-The president delivered
a primetime address last night
on the government shutdown that
he started over his border wall.
For more on this, it's time for
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
This was Trump's first
Oval Office address.
Normally,
that's a solemn occasion,
and one of the weightiest things
a president does.
But as usual, Trump found a way
to make it weird.
After the speech,
he tweeted,
"Thank you.
So many nice comments
regarding my
Oval Office speech --
a very interesting
experience."
"A very interesting
experience"?
He reacted to addressing
the nation from the Oval Office
the same way my grandpa did
to tapas.
[ Laughter ]
Also, if it was
so interesting,
why didn't you
open you eyes more?
[ Laughter ]
You could have fit 10 of yours
into one Pelosi.
[ Laughter ]
[ Distinct laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love jokes
about politics.
It's a great joke.
-Whoa, whoa.
I have a question.
Andy...
Andy, what are you
doing out here?
-Oh, nothing. I just figured,
since "Closer Look"
is the thing from the show
everyone watches online,
I'd try to be in it
and get some views.
What's up, YouTube?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, people watch
this show live.
-Eh.
-Just get out of here.
-Watch "Brooklyn Nine-Nine"
on Thursday!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now everyone's gonna
want to do that.
Now, it's worth
taking a step back
and remembering
how we got here.
We all know the wall was
the most memorable promise
of Trump's campaign, and
refrained at all of his rallies.
And no matter he much he talked
about building a physical wall,
to many of his supporters,
the wall remained
an imaginary thing.
We're at a weird point where
Trump is basically the last guy
who wants a wall.
I mean, it's fun to chant
"Build the wall,"
but they didn't
expect it to happen
any more than they expected
Trump to actually lock her up.
If you go to a Mets game,
you chant "Let's go Mets,"
but you don't really
expect them to go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which might explain why, early
on, there were so few details
about how the wall
would actually be built.
In fact, it took a question
from a child in the crowd
at one of Trump's rallies
in 2015
to find out what the wall
would even be made of.
First, here's the question --
-Okay. A young man --
come on. Young guy.
-So, you're going to
build the wall.
What's it going
to be made out of?
-Oh.
-[ Mockingly ] "Oh."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, [bleep]. Why did I
let a kid ask a question?"
[ Laughter ]
I will say -- I hate
watching Trump be president,
but I would love
watching a show
where kids get to
ask him questions.
[ High-pitched voice ]
"Mr. Trump, where do
people go when they die?"
-They're going to China.
They're going to Japan.
They're going
all over the place.
"Grandpa's in Japan!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
But amazingly, the exchange
with Trump gets weirder,
because Trump then
invited the kid on stage
to repeat his question
while holding him up to the mic.
And eventually,
Trump gave him an answer.
-Lift him up here.
Bring him up here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
-What -- what are the walls
going to be made...?
-Go ahead.
Ask it.
-What are the walls
going to be made out of?
-I'll tell you what it's
gonna be made of.
It's gonna be made
of hardened concrete,
and it's gonna be made out of
rebar and steel.
-Why does he hold
the kid up like that?
[ Laughter ]
That kid's face looks like he's
being carried away by a falcon.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So...
[ Applause ]
...Trump said very clearly
the wall would be made
from concrete.
In fact,
as the campaign went on,
and even after
he became president,
he made lots of specific
promises about the wall --
who would pay for it,
what we should call it,
and how high it would be.
He also repeatedly floated
a price tag for the wall --
a price tag that
seemed to change
basically any time
he opened his mouth.
-So, let's say it costs
$4 billion or $5 billion.
So, if the wall costs
$6 billion to build...
You mean to tell me I can't take
$7 billion and build a wall?
Well, it's probably
$8 billion.
The wall is $10 billion
to $12 billion.
I think for $18 billion or less,
we're gonna have a great wall.
We're talking about a wall
for $20 billion.
And they did agree to
a $25 billion wall.
-He's a like a rich guy
yelling from the
"Price Is Right" audience
who doesn't know
how much things cost.
"How much is this detergent?"
"3 billion. $3 billion."
Trump just made stuff up
off the top of his head
because the wall
was a ridiculous thing
he never thought he'd actually
have to build.
At any point in
the last two years,
Republicans -- who controlled
the House and Senate --
could have given Trump
money for the wall,
but the didn't, because
it was obviously insane.
And now, in his desperation
to get a deal,
he's throwing out everything
he said about the wall
on the campaign trail -- from
the fact that Mexico would pay
for 100% of it, to the fact that
it would be made of concrete,
to the fact that it had to
be called a "wall."
-You ran your campaign
promising supporters
that Mexico was going to
pay for the wall...
-Oh, here we go again.
-...and that the wall was
going to be made of concrete.
-I said I was gonna
build a wall.
I never said
"I'm gonna build a concrete --"
I said
"I'm gonna build a wall."
Just so you don't --
'cause I know you're not into
the construction business --
steel is stronger than concrete.
If I build this wall,
or fence,
or anything the Democrats
need to call it --
because I'm not into names,
I'm into production.
So, if I have
a steel wall --
or you could call it
a steel "fence."
We mentioned
the price that we want --
$5.6 billion --
very strongly.
'Cause numbers
are thrown around.
You heard much
higher numbers.
Those higher numbers
were very much a misnomer.
You heard $20 billion
and $25 billion.
-Yeah, that's true.
We did hear that --
from you.
You told us it would cost
anywhere from $4 billion
to $20 billion,
Mexico would pay for it,
it would be a wall,
not a fence,
and you told a child
it would be made of concrete.
Although, I'm sure
it's not the first time
Trump has lied to a child.
[ As Trump ]
"Oh, no, of course, Eric.
You're definitely
on the will."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] We are in a
self-inflicted political crisis
right now because Trump
made up something dumb,
didn't think it through, and
backed himself into a corner.
He had two years of
total Republican control
to get it done,
and he didn't.
And then, Democrats
took control of the House,
and Trump said...
-Oh.
This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]